[Musique]
cette année ce spot pour une chaîne de
pharmacies allemandes et très populaires
sur les réseaux sociaux
on y voit un vieil homme s'entraîner
tout au long de l'année à soulever un
poids chaque jour jusqu'au réveillon de
noël où l'on comprend enfin pourquoi
[Musique]
du côté de saintes o'neal en gros dans
le gers ont opté cette année pour un
père noël mobile le père noël s'est
installé dans une remorque accompagné de
chants de lumière et ils s'arrêtaient
devant les maisons pour le bonheur des
enfants résultats un habitant a appelé
la gendarmerie pour dire que marseille
ou encore de regarder ce père janvier en
bourgogne
ces terres vêtue de sa robe de bure
renard ou rosicky distribué dans la nuit
du 31 décembre au 1er janvier et non pas
à d'où son nom la descente ça n'avait
rien à voir puisque je rappelle que
avant le 25 décembre c'était la
naissance du christ gibbs a jamais été
les histoires du père noël c'est arrivé
que tu veux dire que noël était une fête
religieuse
c'était un pur hasard à blois
le père noël a tout simplement
démissionner ce week-end il explique que
sa mission était déjà compliquée avec le
respect des gestes barrières mais ce
week-end lors de sa déambulation dans
les rues il explique avoir essuyé des
insultes des parents qui disent à leurs
enfants je cite que le père noël est une
ordure
sans parler des propos bien plus
injurieux cette fois qui est un petit
rayon de soleil qui apparaît à travers
les persiennes quelqu'un qui l'est c'est
un brutalement ses canons enfin il a
déjà annoncé les russes et les lisais
annoncé ce matin qu emmanuel macron été
positif conformément aux consignes
sanitaires il va s'isoler pendant sept
jours et continuer à assurer ses
fonctions à distance mais sa présidence
était cyril hanouna ben voilà on est en
direct jeudi est ce que sarah est ce que
ça va pas là avec avec ce qu il dirait
voilà
non ni pas chaque fois on essaie de
savoir si c'est bon si c'est pas bon si
ça va mieux
bien entendu vous savez que je peux
intervenir père médecin dès la fin du
mois les premières vaccinations
devraient être effectués cette étape
concernera 1 millions de français les
personnes les plus âgées accueillies
dans des établissements comme les ehpad
et certains de leurs soignants
présentant des comorbidités 7 500 sans
gloire
raconter la vie vous raconter l'histoire
la petite vie
il me suis vraiment trompé tromper
complètement
ah je suis désolé mais tu en direct et
fera c'est la vie les moussons les
oiseaux sauvages qu'on ne rattrape
jamais quand ils sont lâchés et des
camps et ne riez pas bah non
malheureusement c'est cd compact
simplement décompte des secondes et des
cons il y en a beaucoup
d'abord c'est vrai que elie parfois y
prend émeuvent des autres mais c'est de
bonne guerre
elle lui aussi je vais prendre ma meuf
on embrasse françois hollande qui
[Applaudissements]
s'éteint bronze en patine des patines
d'oreiller patine verte signée parking
signé par des cons des quoi dès qu'on y
en a partout
attention messieurs c'est pas tout de
suite passagers assure claire chazal on
se tourne juste vers sébastien pour
souhaiter à nos téléspectateurs une
excellente soirée j'ai dit une grosse
bêtise ou du passage des arts sur claire
chazal avec lazard lola va y aller vite
et j'ai fait encore pire que vous le
haut dans le derrière mais sans le dire
kamini non plus nathalie dans le
derrière
oui bah ça n'est pas parce que vous êtes
bien élu et donc tu expliques tu es sûr
c'est sûr c'est très spécial
alors c'est pas le petit prince et moi
j'ai mis une petite graine dans le
ventre à maman ces mamans et après la
petite graine a poussé un poussin a
poussé un bébé maintenant dans son genre
l'animal l'animal qui tue le plus
d'êtres humains sur la planète saine
moustiques c'est le moustique oui c'est
vrai les insectes l'adresse la taille ne
fait pas tout luca voyez ce que je veux
dire
on est d'accord c'est quand ce sera plus
grand t'as pas de grain droit quand tu
seras plus grande d'un drap drm ça c'est
trop de cette radio après c'est nous qui
allons s'en occuper très bon voire j'ai
pas donné de soutien gorge mais j'ai
donné un nom à mais nenê a voté mais oui
il s'appelle kim et kenny c'est donc
l'information de la nuit entre qui a
donc colorées ses cheveux en bleu mais
je dirais même en schtroumpfs une
peinture bleue tantôt comparé à une
gomme tantôt à des bonbons quand ce
n'est pas à une queue de billard autre
match autre look très commentée avec en
espagne les treize d'antoine griezmann
certains pensent pas fifi brindacier
d'autres à laura ingalls bref sa chambre
tout ça ça cache du sun moi je sens bien
je vous avais le sommes là ça se sent
une espèce de dépression une expression
les deux jeunes c'est d'une vraiment une
dépression de jeu de la mélancolie c'est
plutôt les collines encore il ya des
poètes qui leurs employés mais elle le
simple ça va venir
des rappeurs même le conservatoire du
jeune youval est fermé une sorte de
douche froide pour lui et tous ses amis
musiciens qui ont le sentiment d'avoir
été abandonné par le monde politique
[Musique]
je précise que ce sont les salariés de
la compagnie vent
[Musique]
le meilleur moyen de n'échangez aucune
donnée personnelle sans déconner alors